[Music]
I'm open-minded that's why I went to
Brazil really
would be staying in the United States
yeah hey if you don't want to be here
I get out you don't want to be here you
have freedom to leave that's the beauty
of America I'm gonna be gone before the
weekend is up
yes chef Don I remember that now I'm
sorry
um to answer your question it can happen
that you get naked in front of someone
and then you decide to change your mind
use your passport
I do I have my Venezuela I'm talking to
the men okay the men watching Everybody
Get the lights
on one more thing yeah we'll go ahead
real quick so the reason why we were all
laughing at the one thing of oh do I
have your consent do I have your consent
on a balance of probabilities a lot of
times that does not happen right I'm not
saying I'm just jumping on women
but the the point where you get your
consent is where you go in to kiss a
girl or when you start to take off your
clothes a lot of people aren't saying do
I have your consent it's kind of like an
implied
I think that should change that's just
the reality keep your clothes on please
don't change it
if you don't if you don't want to have
sex in this day and age especially with
men yeah mid court is hashtag
I really think that because there's a
lot of women the metoo movement I really
think that it would behoove you to ask
women that you're hooking up with do I
still have your consent because a lot of
them are lying yeah
at which at what point do do we draw the
line is it each article of clothing
all right
and vibing
so what if you vibed it two times does
that invalidate in my personal
experience I had a dude that was 21 that
asked me twice once before once before
taking off her clothes and the second
time as I mentioned mid-coitis
okay well not here I want to hear your
critiques for for these three though
after honestly I could I just like a
group critique could I do that yeah if
you can if you got something that's for
all don't generalize yeah I mean I
prefer my critique individual yeah don't
generalize it you've been on the
internet
yeah because y'all are just throwing out
random numbers okay I'll invite I just
kind of it's all the same same thing for
everybody but I just want to feel
special here so I mean we're all yeah
yeah everybody's different we're all
special like we all have value okay so I
just you know to you it's been very nice
I mean it's I thank you for I thank you
for being here everybody and I'm honored
to be here
um I know my view take is kind of
different from like secular dating and
that's fine that's why I'm here
um but for you I mean nice meeting you
obviously I disagree with almost
everything you say
um I think you said one thing I was like
uh yeah maybe but still wasn't a full
agreement
um I mean I don't know any of you guys
or any of your platforms or anything so
I'm just kind of going off of like what
I hear today I went in blind I didn't
know the topics either but um I just
kind of urge you to this kind of goes
with everybody but kind of reevaluate
the definition of value because you're
saying like oh this person doesn't have
value this person doesn't have value we
all have value yeah
um different people have different views
on where that value comes from for me
it's from God
um you know people have passed people
have been to prison people have
committed crimes people have
committed adultery like horrible things
and they can change and they can turn
around from that and I believe in
miracles every day like we're all
walking Miracles and I know I've had my
own health issues and it was a miracle
they found it because I could have had a
stroke at 29 and I'm pretty fit you know
going back to all that
um but like it's it's a blessing to be
here and just you have value you have
value and you have value
um I disagree with everything that y'all
say
really
um but I urge you to kind of you know
reevaluate that I didn't say that anyone
doesn't have value I said they have less
value okay well still I disagree with
that and I also I also said sexual
market value yeah okay I didn't say
personal value I said sexual market so
yeah I disagree with that I think
everyone does have market value I think
sexual market value is like your value
in the sexual Market okay so so like
like for example a 21 year old and an 85
year old woman like there's more guys
lined up to date a 21 year old woman
than an 85 year old woman okay and
that's thank you for your opinion that's
not an opinion yeah I think you're not a
goddamn opinion you're just I would love
to go down the line
no [ __ ] that
thank you very much for saying that you
were so accurate and she was so
inaccurate okay and you're well my
original point was we all do have value
I'll be
the health issue issue which I'm about
fertility I think that's what you're
alluding to fertility specifically then
yes and they're so unattractiveness
subjective 85 year old woman I would
love to finish a point okay
wow thanks appreciate that thank you
um but there's so many kids and I work
with foster care kids as well through my
non-profit there's so many kids in the
foster care system that need a home so
even if you are older and you're not
able to have children there's people in
their 20s that are not able to have
children there are kids you can't foster
and yes it is expensive but you make
time for things you care about and you
put money towards things you care about
so it's possible you can go and adopt
and go and Foster and if hey if I'm if I
never get married there's worse things
in the world I would love to adopt a
child in the foster care system maybe
that of a minority Community as well
because there's a lot of kids that are
from the minority communities that are
in foster care and that's my passion so
I will fulfill my goals of being a mom
whether a man or not is involved but I
just kind of urge you like the sexual
market value I don't like how we're
talking about humans like we're talking
about cars so I just kind of urge you
guys to reevaluate that definition I
think you're conflating uh you know I
don't think you know the definition of
value right so whenever she's saying
sexual market value that means that two
men right this demographic of what this
demographic of women is more attractive
right so you're saying you're coming at
it from in a an opinion what you're
doing I feel like all of us have value
right in our own ways when she's saying
it it's a fact right more men like
younger women than men like 85 year old
women that is a fact that's not an
opinion that is a fact isn't there like
a high STD rate with amongst older
people right now especially because
they're having a lot of sex in old
people homes like isn't that but like I
mean oh they don't know that
the STD is not leaving the nursing home
then right like what you're talking
about it would you date an 85 year old
man maybe she likes that would anybody
like it yes or no I personally like
younger so like yeah
personal opinions there's gold diggers
out there
are you rude yes or no
right like so that's what we're saying
go to build a house right would you hire
me or would you hire a house no because
they have more value
I mean if you're new and you're starting
the house building business I might hire
you give you a shot if you're a young
man looking for a job those Chick-fil-A
workers I love them they're young and
they're at it working hard
this is the crazy thing like
like the red is so strong with you where
I I know you know what we're saying but
you just pretend you're a lot of people
I think we all want to be right no right
I think when you're arguing that an 85
year old woman and a 21 year old woman
have the same amount of suitors it's
just a need to be right okay cool thanks
going back to my turn to talk
um again just you I like and appreciate
you because you have you were the most
respectful
um we still were lacking some respect on
this side as well I tried to listen I'll
speak for myself I could have been
better about that
um which I I'm happy to work on but
appreciate you voicing your opinions
again urge you to kind of reevaluate how
you view women how you view
relationships because I see we want this
traditional relationship but we're also
not practicing those Traditional Values
in our dating life so I kind of urge you
to practice what you preach For You
Austin
um I
um I admire your strength and being
wanting to be right and your strength in
voicing your opinions don't do that
um that's I just
I don't know I my mommy always told me
found everything nice to say don't say
anything at all so I'm gonna leave it at
that well another thing you say is true
that's why again truth honestly truth to
me the Bible That's truth to me that
it's it's different for everybody
so if you don't yeah and I would love to
do that and even if I can't have kids or
it's too late for me or I never get
married oh my God they're the worst
thing in the world which is not
um I can take a child into my home and
raise that child as my own that's
selfish adopting a child is selfish
selfish it's selfish to be a single
mother and not bring it and not I think
it's better than foster home you're
putting you're putting the kid at every
statistical disadvantage give it to
someone with two pairs no no and I
actually know a lot about adoption
because my parents adopted three kids
yeah and and I know a lot of the issues
that come with the Foster system and
I've actually experienced a lot of them
firsthand yes but I would I I would
never even on my three siblings wish
them to be in a single parent home I
think that is incredibly selfish as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible